presented by dot by Todd Hoffman founder
and CEO of 3s scam I am Marjorie torus
of lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by libraries labyrinth is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
three of time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming Todd Hoffman
I will now turn the presentation over to
him hi thanks for having me I'm Todd
Hoffman I'm the CEO CCN and we're a
computational pathology company there's
maybe two words that you don't hear very
often and certainly not together
so first addictiveness becca pathology
and why it's important so pathology is
the practice of looking at microscopic
features in tissue to understand what's
going on in the underlying tissue is
very specifically as it relates to
disease and so in biology you start off
as a z name is RNA protein cells tissues
organs all the way up to yield you're
looking at a whole organism
you're doing radiology with a look at
molecules you're doing molecular biology
but as those molecules start to form and
the proteins are performing to cells
tissues and organs this is really where
you get tissue scale structures where
the microscopic detail is really key in
understanding what's going on with the
tissue and that and from a pathology
pathology perspective you're using those
to understand what's going on in the
disease also to help develop cures for
disease and then once you have
therapeutics to help in the diagnosis
this matters in a lot of diseases the
big one is cancer and so that sort of
illustrates something that we think are
important this is a model of the
subtypes of the subclones
of a tumor over time and so as the tumor
grows it involves against itself and you
get different underlying genotypes which
translate into different tumor
phenotypes and say when you give a
chemotherapy you'll kill a lot of the
cancer but not all of it and then what's
remaining is resistance to treatment
that you gave and so what we grows are
resistant clothes and so it's not just
cancer disease like Alzheimer's disease
cardiovascular disease diabetes live
tissue fibrosis these all have tissue
scale structures that have an impact on
on the disease and so it's really
important to be able to understand them
so that the classic pathologist image is
someone like this a pathologist is an MD
who's not undergone additional training
in that specialty
they use their eyeballs to look through
a microscope and a tissue that they're
moving around with their hands kind of
looks like the background
you'll see this in every hospital and in
every pharmaceutical company in every
University lab in the United States one
issue that concerns us here at Sapien is
that the workflow hasn't really changed
so this is my favorite pathologist
remote
Hall he got the Nobel Prize for his work
in neuroscience and did really amazing
work but notice that he's sitting in the
exact same position that the modern
pathologist is today and the workflow
that pathologist used hasn't really
changed since the 1880s this is a
problem because this workflow was really
designed for human hands human eyes and
human mind and a human centric
decision-making process with an
underlying menial workflow and so the
pathologist who's shuffling around these
sec need slices of tissue on pieces of
glass they can only go through about 350
sections in a day the workflow is also
so much more than this classic image
that you see there's the entire front
end of the process that's entirely
manual as well was handled by technician
well they start off with the full biopsy
and then they grossly dissect it then
they process the tissue into blocks then
use a microtome to thinly slice the
tissue mount it to glass and I want the
phone last you can stain it and then
finally you hand it off to the
pathologist for their decision making
process the consequence of this Maino
workflow is that what the pathologist
actually looks at is a very tiny
fraction of the actual tissue that came
out of the the animal or the patient so
you think you know me order like a
millionth of a percent of the actual
tissue in non biology terms one analogy
I like to use is that the manual
workflow is like trying to understand a
movie but you're just looking at 12
randomly selected skills from the cell
so here we've got a random change from
Fight Club you can get an idea what's
going on here if you have a lot of
imagination or in the case of
pathologists a lot of training in a lot
of hard work and yeah it's not easy so
what we're going to sleep in is we are
redesigning the
workflow optimizing it away from human
hands humanized in the human mind and
optimizing instead for the way that
robots move perceive and think and so
here's an example of one component of
the machine so that the goal of this
component is to cut the tissue and image
it simultaneously which which
classically is done is to separate
workflow so let's write what's like here
in the diagram is a custom diamond blade
that diamonds are the hardest material
in distance and they're also transparent
and so you can shine light through a
diamond of whether it's a pretty on
rings and so what we do is we we run
fiber optics down the back of this arm
that holds the blade and then we couple
the fiber optics with the back of the
blade and then we shine light through
the blame and so the blade is literally
glowing and then we have optics that we
focus on the bevel of the blade and so
now we're staring at the bevel of blade
and we have a camera that's on the back
of the optics that we use to continually
image the bevel of the blade the tissues
and goes on a robotic arm which is then
sliced across the knife and then the arm
is a sync with the sensor so that as the
tissue passes over the blade it gets
digitized and this is all done without
any human hands involved in the workflow
and so the we get our image in a fully
automated fashion without any manual
handling there are a number of other
unique components of the machine this is
a picture of it it doesn't look anything
like a conventional microscope there's
no place to put your head because it's
fully digital and then and then we also
are redesigning other parts of the
workflow because the pathology is not
just the
looking at the picture it's starting at
the biopsy and so so we start with the
biopsy and we're also building
automation tools that do a better job of
automating species processing and the
staining and then we also do a lot of
work on the data processing side
building algorithms that do filtering
segmentation classification and
reconstruction of the tissue and as
you'll see in a moment we also do 3d
visualization and quantitative analysis
of the tissue structures by redesigning
the workflow in the way that we are
we're able to dramatically increase the
speed and so we're a human could be at
350 sections per day each of our robots
can do about 20,000 sections per day so
at this point you probably want to see
what some of the data looks like so I'm
going to show you next is a mouse kidney
where we have stained the the kidney for
blood vessels and so what we're doing
right now is we are flying through the
samples in black those blog those of the
glomeruli which is the functional
working into the kidney one of the
things you'll notice is that the
features line up in 3d in the classic
pathology workflow when you mount the
tissue on the glass it gets warped and
torn which makes it impossible to really
line the features up in 3d and so in
classic pathology you're really
restricted to two-dimensional
examination of structures and as you
know reality structurally is
three-dimensional now as you might
imagine this produces a lot of data each
of the machines producing about 75
terabytes of data per day which is
frankly more than a human can look at
and so instead of looking at the data in
two-dimensional sections we move to a
three-dimensional space and so this is
that same kidney where we've down
sampled it in order to fit on the screen
or rotating it and so at this scale you
can see the major blood vessels and
those smaller flex those are the
glomeruli
the kidney right I wanted to show this
field so you can see that we can fit a
whole organ into the system now master
knew pretty small but we can fit up to
about 125 cubic centimeters into the
skillet at one time we just finished a
project imaging an entire macaque heart
which is something that I run the
numbers but if you wanted to do that
level of imaging in the conventional
fashion it wiII be a careers worth of
imaging whereas for us it's a couple
days on one of the on one of the systems
now this is this is heavily down painful
to never fit on the screen if we zoom in
this is now a high-resolution we can see
microscopic features those are the
glomeruli and and if you can see we can
trace those features through in 3d if we
were to show the whole kidney at this
resolution it would be about 35 feet
tall so even in 3d it's too much for a
human to naively search through the
entire space and so what we have on our
team is a software group who takes the
3d data and cleans up the data and then
segments classifies and reconstruction
reconstruct it and so what you're
looking here is a small segment of the
vasculature but you're not looking at
the pixel intensity that came through
the microscope what you're looking at is
a visualization of a structure those put
into the database because the algorithm
creates the features through right into
a database and allows us to work with it
in more sophisticated fashion for
instance in this visualization I
selected this vascular segment and said
show me all of the vasculature connected
in this segment and then fade everything
else out to 50% which allowed me to zero
in and examine this particular 3d
structure with that structure
highlighted now visualization is very
useful for for menial attending
but at the end of the day what we care
about and what the customers care about
are the decisions that are made out of
out of the data that we produce and so
to that end we take these 3d structures
and then we design quantitative
descriptions of the tissues so here's an
example of that from a paper that were
working on where we've got two different
regions of interest one of the
cerebellum and one for brain and so we
have different dimensions that we can
describe tissue on like here's the
fractional dots along of the tissue this
is the mean distance to the nearest
blood vessel and inside inside a face
and so we have all these statistical
descriptions of the tissue for
vasculature we have about 35 different
metrics the week that we were able to
compute and so we can use these to
typically describe the differences say
between the contingent types or the
difference between healthy and diseased
tissue on a case of a scientific study
different experimental conditions versus
the control and so so we do this
regularly and we have a whole process
for from from beginning to end for
designing this this workflow and really
the goal of what we're doing is we're
trying to take pathology away from being
a manual two dimensional practice into a
high-throughput
quantitative analytical driven science
now you can look at more than just blood
vessels I tend to show those because
most people have an intuitive sense of
what blood vessels look like we can also
look at say different tumor
architectures so three here are three
different team architectures this is
micro cystic trabecular nested
underneath these different phenotypes
they're different they're different
genotypes that reflects different
subclones
of the tumor so we can classify
different architectures we can also look
for very sparse features and here's one
example right here is the convergence of
2-minute static both side in a tumor
and this is where the tumor is
metastasizing and starting to grow down
the blood vessels as our pathologist
said it's starting to chase the food and
this is important in oncology because
most of this tumor is not what's going
to kill the patient what's going to kill
the patient is where it's metastasizing
and it's not spreading through the body
in a conventional pathology workflow you
probably wouldn't have ever found this
because this feature was 500 sections
deep where in a in a conventional
pathology workflow you typically take
you know six or twelve sections out of
the sample and so to find this very
important a very sparse feature in the
manual workflow would take you you know
almost two days and in for us it's
trivial to get to that level and it
turns out that all those different
features those tissue architectures and
the feature that we were looking for
those came out of the same tumor and so
where you started off your cutting would
greatly bias what you see and lead you
and leave the pathologist down different
directions in terms of what they think
they're looking at in terms of the
cancer and so at three scan we're really
designing for doing volumetric pathology
where we can look at very large sections
of tissue whole biopsies or in some
cases you know whole organs that allows
us to more comprehensively characterize
the tissue that we're looking at and so
here here's that that tumor that I just
showed you and what we're doing is we're
sliding through safe camps on the
features in light pink is a t-shirt for
a coma and hot pink are the blood
vessels and then underneath that we have
imagery which shows microscopic scale
features in this in a very large volume
do more than just cancer the cancer is a
big part of what we do here's a quick
example of that this is a biopsy of
human skin in yellow are the peripheral
nerves the
on the left and some muscle on the right
and what we're doing is we're tracing it
here the epidermis and the peripheral
nerves because we're building
quantitative descriptions of peripheral
neuropathy which is a disease in humans
it comes out as sort of a numbness in
the fingers and what's happening is
there's damage that's happening to the
peripheral nerves the symptoms of the
number of diseases and also a side
effect in a number of treatments like
chemotherapy and so from these 3d
reconstructions we can zoom in be very
high level high detail descriptions and
so here's the peripheral nerve bundle
and we can split it out and map out the
individual fascicles and and once
something is digitized and then
reconstructed in 3d we can design
quantitative metrics around that to
further describe and characterize the
tissue but doing it in a statistical
fashion here's a project that we're
working right now where we're looking at
looking at lone tissue into a single
section in this case this is the mouse
lung you know it's 2005 percent of the
sample that we pulled out looking at it
2d and it's a little quick background
anatomy your lungs drops down the the
Airways drop down scale over looking up
down here this large Muslim here is a
bronchial and then as we go through we
see terminal bronchioles respiratory
bronchioles and then the alveoli which
is where the gas exchange happens if the
functional work that that your the lung
does and then if we take and then we
zoom in on a smaller section in dark
purple we can see the pneuma sites and
then we can also pick out the the
Airways and so what I'm going to show
you now is a reconstruction where we are
segmenting out the Airways so these are
either BLV life was resumed in right now
and as we zoom out we're going to drop
away the
the high level high level detail and
start slotting in big chunks of the
belongs and so the thing like the other
video you can see you know how much
detail there is across that whole scale
and in diseases of the lung they can be
very sparse like when you have long
fibrosis it's not just it's not evenly
distributed across lung it's very spotty
in just in different areas until being
able to look at a larger area is very
beneficial and understanding what's
going on and updated on can wear wrap
we're halfway through building our new
lab where we will have 12 of our systems
installed those those are able to do
about 100 million sections per year
across this wall which is one else in
perspective if you wanted to replicate
that it would take you about two-thirds
of all the labs in every Hospital
University and pharmaceutical company in
the United States and is that really
necessary one one analogy that we that
we use is what we're doing to microscopy
kind of like what CT did to x-ray CTS
are a bunch of x-rays that you take and
then you build a three-dimensional model
cities did aren't some one-to-one
replacement for next layer like if you
break your arm you still just get a two
dimensional x-ray because there's no
need to do the 3d well the 3d does is it
opens up these classes of applications
that allow you to do additional things
with the practice and so one example of
this is correlative imaging in in
classic pathology the amount that you
look at is so tiny that if you compare
it to radiology data of the same tissue
you have no idea where it came from
inside that tissue at 3 p.m. because we
can image volumes that are extremely
large we can we can segment to
reconstruct features that you can see in
both the radio
geology and the pathology and so here's
that tumor I showed you earlier was an M
R that was done done previously and so
these vessels we can we can see in both
and then we can use that to to align in
code register the two different datasets
so if you have a radiology data set and
you see something in you there's a
feature that you can't quite resolve in
radiology we can move it over to the
pathology domain look at it under our
automated microscope to register it with
with the radiology so you can get a
side-by-side view at those different
size scales and so you can zoom from
from whole organ down to down to
microscopic level details now once once
here once you're at a higher resolution
you may want to see additional
dimensions such as doing an immediate a
chemical panel or pulling concision up
for sequencing and so we built a system
on our scopes which allows us to capture
some of the tissue and then put it into
a more conventional workflow and so
these are sections from that mouse-kini
that I showed you earlier where the
section is coming to our scope was
captured and put onto glass now once
it's on blast you can then run it down
conventional pipelines and so here what
we've done is we've taken taken the
kidney and then added stains or cell
bodies and then immunised and for smooth
muscle so the block is you are the
original blood vessels and and now you
can see you know the kidney tubules
coming this way when this one was cut
perpendicular interleaving with with
blood vessels this dis allows you to get
a more classic two-dimensional
microscopic view but you now instead of
just having this very high resolution
but otherwise isolated piece of imagery
you can now go register it back into the
3d the larger some whole organ level
pathology that we do you can Co register
it to radiology and you can also look at
a statistical description of the 3d
tissue structure which in combination
this is a lot more powerful than than
just regular 2d pathology also once it's
done laughs you can add an additional
dimensionality so you can micro dissect
the tissue and run it through DNA
sequencing you can take it do you know
look at the RNA with microarrays you can
do immunochemical panels or mass spec or
any number of other molecular
investigations and bring that back in Co
register it with the 3d pathology and
with the radiology and so if the priests
can literally see the world is we see
biology being a multi modal and multi
scale state investigation states and so
we're mapping out collaborations and
integrations with other technology with
other technologies that move from the
whole organism scale down to a single
molecule and are doing to an irrational
pipeline so that we can really take a
good look at biology in its true self
which is or to multi scale that's the
end of the content that I prepared for
today again my name is Todd Hoffman from
3 p.m. and if you have any questions
that would love to answer them now or
we're running out of time
we can also answer questions via email
my email is Todd at cbn.com or I believe
you can also ask questions through this
platform care thank you
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
head three questions into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is how does this work do resend
tissues or is this equipment installed
at our facility good question right now
we run the company basically is a
specialized CRO where we do large scale
imaging projects for our customers who
are usually pharmaceutical companies for
universities that are doing preclinical
drug discovery research so the workflow
is we work with the customer or the
collaborator to develop a protocol and
then the tissue is sent over here and we
do most of the tissue prep all the
imaging and then the analysis
is this a replacement for 2d slides this
isn't a one-to-one replacement for 2d
slides because there are constraints on
what sorts of things you can do with it
and the data is slightly different
because it's three-dimensional one way
to think about this with an analogy is
it's kind of like what CT is to a 2d
x-ray if you break your arm you go to
hospital and you get it to the x-ray
because there's no reason to do a CT
scan just limit simple broken arm
what this is is taking lots of images
and then reconstructing things in 3d to
be much more sophisticated 3d
information the end data ends up being a
bit different because it's
three-dimensional so two-dimensional so
you also change how you do the
interpretation you have a pathologist
manual examining the imagery so we have
a pathologist on our team who we've
trained on how to how to interpret the
the imagery the reconstruction and the
analytics that we do and when we send
back results the top line of the
reportedly sent back is the human
pathologist opinion of what's going on
with notes on why they're coming to that
conclusion and we also send back in
addition to the human analysis we also
send statistics statistics
reconstructions and imagery that that
our collaborators can view either
through a browser interface we have a
web viewer for our data or we can also
send raw data if we're working as
someone who has in-house dementia
imaging a house with capabilities okay
we have time for one more question what
software packages do you use to analyze
the result so unfortunately there's no
off-the-shelf software that's capable of
dealing with as much data that we
produced
each of our machines produce about
seventy five terabytes of imagery per
day and when the process of building a
lab with probe machines and so by
December we'll be producing close to a
petabyte of data per day and so it's too
much for anything else to sell so we
built all of our own internal software
that's capable of handling the data
volumes that we produce we we do have a
lot of familiarity with off-the-shelf
packages like like a rivas or image day
and that they're more classically used
and so we can export data in formats
that customers can put into software
packaging that they already house I
would like to once again thank Todd
Hoffman for his presentation I would
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August
25th 2017 you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye